[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir
pas trop le temps est humide ce soit
notre petit escargot doit être très
content savez vous que les escargots
sorte quand il pleut oh non je ne savent
pas mais moi je n'aime pas la pluie
je préfère la nar elle me fait
abondantes ou tout blanc
olsen a tout de suite patron qui s'est
caché
bonsoir mes petits mais tu sais ton ami
l'escargot je lui apporte une salade
mais elle en a déjà
il est plus là comment sont les
bienvenus il s'est caché il ne peut pas
aller bien loin
nous allons le chercher petit escargot
petit minot nounours t'as portes de la
salle à
du coup il n'est pas sur la cheminée
non non j'ai regardé peut-être sous
ledit petit escabeau ya eu notamment de
l'incendié pas à personne beau le coquin
il se cache et regarder dans la salle de
bains dans la baignoire et pas dans le
lavabo
naples est bon c'est un vilain quotas
c'est peut-être caché dans la salle anne
pow d'autres cherchent on ne voit pas
pousser non plus petit score pour moi je
crois que ma raison pas pourquoi elle
dit que les escargots
ils doivent rester à la campagne n'en
est pas le lieu est un métal a doucement
les enfants j'étais pas bien cela le
voile
je ne trouvais et didot il s'en allait
qu'être en conteneurs ce le pauvre petit
il a envie de retourner à la campagne
dans une prairie bien faire
alors qu'est-ce qu'on veut tuer un même
nounou et on ira le voir à la campagne
darko allons petit escargot dit bonsoir
à nicolas et a pas preneur
parfois petit escargot en vo petit mode
et nous on va se coucher tout seul que
des gants pour son annonce pas de nuit
tenus nicolas preniez pimprenelle qu'en
bien
où
[Musique]
aux nuits les enfants
à te voilà nounours me voilà pas trop
peu regardé qui joorawon il s'ennuyait
le pauvre petit on leur apporte chez lui
patron excellente idée et nounours en
route vers luchon du score go à demain
les enfants fait pour eux
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]